good morning believe nation today's
message is don't be ashamed of your past
over to you 50 cent I think the things
you go to make who you are
I don't regret those things I don't
regret them because I don't think I'd be
Who I am today if I wasn't exposed to
those situations if you asked me would i
those are unfortunate situations that
I've had the experience and if I had a
choice I would have definitely went in a
different direction I might want want to
go to school for business instead of
having to go through that this portion
of my life so this is a really important
topic because I think being ashamed of
our past holds back a lot of people from
doing what they really want to do and I
remember in my first software company I
was ashamed of my past and I held us
back we were selling scientific software
and I was ashamed that I wasn't a
scientist and I was ashamed I didn't
have enough experience and I was ashamed
that I was too young and I was selling
to researchers who had PhDs who were
three times as old as I was and I was I
was too ashamed and too afraid to even
talk to them because I felt like I
didn't have enough experience and it
wasn't until I really realized that I
could provide value to them and they
didn't care about my experience in my
background whether it was a scientist or
not as long as I was providing value to
them that was what was making the
difference for them and so I would
encourage you to look at the same thing
in your business what are you ashamed of
what are you afraid of know what in your
past is kind of holding you back from
doing something great now and
understanding that nobody really cares
you know how nobody really cares about
your past all they care about is what
can you do for me right now and if you
can provide somebody with tremendous
value then you can build a successful
business and matter what your background
is and so my question is day for you
today is what are you ashamed of you
know this is uh this is going deep this
is a more personal question of the day
than usual but what I want you to do is
try to release that you know get it out
there and you'll realize that people
don't really care about it so share what
are you ashamed of that you feel
- back in your business leave them
comments below on the joining discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso